hello again thank you once again for
clicking on my face you know i always
love you for that i appreciate you for
that sometimes i forget to say it but
it's always true i feel it in here and
before we get started i do want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by dr squatch dr squatch
is a longtime sponsor of this channel
because i'm a long time user of their
product dr squash is changing the way
men approach personal care with high
performance natural products that leave
you smelling great looking your best
feeling like a champion not only do they
have shower soap they have deodorant
beard oil the scent is crushed pine
otherwise known as happiness in a bottle
shampoo and conditioner and yes i do use
the shampoo and conditioner as well as
the soap they have really convenient
subscription plans with extra savings
you just never run out because let's
face it most of us know that we've run
out of something
when we run out of something and they
have a 100 satisfaction guarantee if
you're not satisfied with their product
you get your money back no questions so
click the link below and use promo code
dsq john's and new customers get 20 off
of your purchase of 20 or more and thank
you once again to dr squash for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
and now to quote a great epic badass
hunter from history i think he said it
best when he said
i might be paraphrasing
so prey is a predator prequel a film i i
put no stock in because what can i say
history has taught me frequent aside
history has taught me never to get
excited for new predator movies yeah
there have been some gems that have
shined through before i thought
predators was good predator 2 i like i
know i guess a lot of [ __ ] i enjoy it i
went through my phase of thinking it was
lame and then as i aged i just
appreciated it for what it was those
movies from that weird time where they
brought everything to the city i mean
jason took manhattan as for the first
movie of course it does go without say
it was quite naturally perfect it was a
work of art but pray takes place in the
1700s it stars amber mid thunder she
plays this young native american girl
she's a total underdog she's a great
tracker and she's like there's something
out here that's not a bear and we all
need to be prepared and now she has to
take on the predator because it's an
underdog story a coming of age story
coming of age stories when they're
executed well i always enjoy those also
i like rooting for underdogs this is a
formula that works for me i guess
because this movie is like they finally
recognized they got it this light bulb
went off in their heads after decades
this movie takes it back to a big part
of what made predator great and that's
the scale of it it's smaller scale if
you look at the original predator it's a
few marines in the jungle unbeknownst to
them there's a bigger badass in the
trees and they're being hunted they're
like we are not the apex predators on
the planet right now but it is smaller
scale and i appreciate the fact this
movie did that i don't know what the
budget for this movie did whenever i say
small scale people always they go on box
office mojo and start throwing the
budget at me like oh it costs 100
million dollars it's not small scale i'm
not talking about budget i'm talking
about the scale of the film how it feels
like the personal
tone of the film itself i guess that's
what i'm trying to say is the the film
feels more personal in a good way like
the first one you have the predator
human beings and nature which means
actually for the first half an hour of
this movie it's character development
you're getting to know this this girl
you get to know her and her brother the
relationship between the two how other
comanche view her some tension that
might be there's actually there are a
few moments of tension
a couple that have to do with the dog
she's her buddy she has a dog with her
and i was like i just anytime the dog
was in peril or running from something
i'm like oh it's a predator movie hope
hopefully the predator's like not a
threat this thing i always liked about
the predator 2 which is still enacted
here that dude has a code of conduct he
has a rule a rule of ethics it's amazing
what a code of conduct can do for a
character i think that's one of the
reasons predators just stood the test of
time just as a creature as a character
in a movie you want me to talk about the
violence don't you you say this i know
it's so much fun the violence in this
movie i thought was really satisfying
but not visually visually i was like why
do they keep cutting away is it supposed
to is are they trying to go for pg-13
because it's clearly not pg-13 it's
clear that it's r but sometimes it
doesn't show everything happening
however violence and creative kills
those are two different things the two
are not equal this movie goes to
creative kill route and in that some of
these kills they were just downright fun
mortal kombat fan for life like super
fan judge me from that lens i'm saying
some of these i was like that
is straight up that's all the energy of
a fatality right there but where it's
really satisfying was the sound design
the sound design
made the kills it actually made all the
hits it's that satisfying modern mortal
kombat-esque sound design when
something's getting ripped up slashed
gutted decapitated it's amazing what
sound design can do for a movie
and death this is streaming on hulu so
if you watch it
watch it with a badass pair of
headphones you let me know how that is
and for more praise for pray there is a
gripe that i have for a lot of movies
where i say the movie's too long or it
drags on too long could have trimmed 15
minutes off of it praise about an hour
and 40 minutes that includes credits i
feel like this movie was it's in the
pocket i don't know why movies seem
afraid now to have a 90 minute good
times i was like no it has to be at
least two hours also personal gripe this
is me subjective just personal bitching
about things the predator creature
designs like as the movies go on doesn't
matter when it takes place past present
future whenever it's like they're
getting more and more monstrous i like
the simplicity of the original predator
design that i would love for them to
bring that back because that's just that
was perfect i did like how this predator
in this movie for a large portion of it
until he was like all right let's bring
out the big guns he just wanted to kill
things with his hands
i
that's badass usually in predator movies
they start breaking out the toys pretty
early this dude was like nah but you
know pummeling and kicking that's fun so
that the predator in this movie was kind
of deliciously savage and that was cool
there were some leaps i had to take i'm
not gonna say they're not but it all you
know it's all about the last act of the
movie i can't talk about it here i feel
like that's why a lot of movies have
their leaps in the last act like ha
people can't talk about it without
spoiling it
so there's that but in short i felt the
end was just too easy i didn't feel
too much payoff with it but regardless
for the most part this movie i thought
it was solid it was a solid good time i
liked the lead i like the underdog story
i like the coming of age story and i
like the fact this movie celebrates what
made predator great while making its own
story it's its own movie in its own
right it's not like it just emulates the
first predator and that's that i'll say
it was a solid fun time no alcohol
required and you don't have to drive to
the movie theater so gas prices take
that in which case you have to pay for
hulu but one month of hulu is one gallon
of gas
so there you go all right so pray have
you seen it are you looking forward to
it or what's your favorite predator
movie i already said i like predator too
there's no need to hide anymore come to
the comments section it's safe here it's
okay whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you